[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
una de las consecuencias más palpables
de la Guerra de Ucrania el escenario de
inflación global vamos a analizarlo con
cuatro invitados en este estudio Álvaro
zúñigo acorde Zúñiga Cordero es
economista doctor de la Paris School of
economics especializado en temas de
desigualdad bienvenido Álvaro Muchas
gracias encantado estar aquí ver aquí
odi profesor experto en economía de la
Universidad de la sorbona bienvenida
Vera
Meghan es macroeconomista experta en
economías de países en desarrollo
bienvenida Megan Gracias hasta aquí y
Carlos
de comercio de Argentina y profesor en
la París School of economics bienvenido
Carlos Hola Carlos
el escenario de inflación derivado de la
Guerra de Ucrania hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
[Música]
la inflación está poniendo en jaque a la
economía global que se acerca a una
recesión en la que caerán varios países
desarrollados en 2023 según ha advertido
el fondo monetario internacional la
invasión rusa de Ucrania que sigue
desestabilizando poderosamente la
economía mundial y ha llevado Europa a
una crisis energética severa así como
una espiral de inflación en todo el
mundo y la desaceleración de la economía
china son a ojos del fmi los factores
que están marcando la evolución
económica mundial Y seguirán haciéndolo
en un futuro próximo una tendencia que
también afecta a América Latina y que
vamos a analizar en el programa de más
de explicar que es esto de la deflación
el nuevo fenómeno que puede tener ahora
una repercusión planetaria antes de
algunas portadas el economista las
medidas para mitigar la inflación han
costado
1,4% del pib de México el comercio de
Perú destaca en esta portada estas
palabras de Hugo Santamaría economista
jefe del apoyo consultoría el poco
crecimiento se va a quedar varios años
vamos analizarlo también este otro
artículo de New York Times pone el
acento en la deflación la primera
deflación global comenzó dice New York
Times y no hay manera de saber qué tan
grave será bueno Álvaro nos aproximamos
un escenario de recesión global casi de
forma irrevocable según el fondo
monetario internacional sí Hay una
posibilidad de un 25% de que el otro año
El 2023 sea un año de muy poco
crecimiento crecimiento nulo y no hay
manera de de
prever que tan grave será ahora lo
importante aquí es que va a atacar a
diferentes regiones del mundo de manera
diferenciada probablemente los países
ricos van a sufrir más y entre ellos hay
diferencias Europa aún más Estados
Unidos un poco menos y América Latina es
una región que estará un poco al medio
de las regiones
emergentes de Asia y África pero va a
estar por debajo del crecimiento de las
regiones de Asia y África pero por
encima del crecimiento de Europa
latinoamérica todo indica que en Estados
Unidos sí que se está al menos moderando
un poco la inflación ahora Qué
implicaciones tiene la situación ahora
mismo de inflación pena en Latinoamérica
bueno Y recordemos que el problema de la
inflación en la región no ha sido un
problema en las últimas décadas a la
excepción de la Argentina que es un
Enigma y de Venezuela el resto de los
países de América Latina han puesto en
marcha políticas bastante eficaces para
luchar contra la inflación la inflación
es ahora digamos un paradigma nuevo la
inflación finalmente es un desajuste es
una respuesta de shock de shock de
actividad de shock de desajustes entre
la oferta y la demanda en lo que
considera América Latina el primer
factor de inflación es por supuesto el
el reciente aumento del precio del
petróleo pero recordemos que la
inflación venía bien antes de el
comienzo de la guerra con Ucrania esto
se explica que sabe la salía la pandemia
con esta recuperación con esta creencia
de bueno de de de aumento de la demanda
aumento de los precios combinado con
problemas de transporte a nivel mundial
hizo que entremos en un proceso
inflacionario agudizado por un problema
escasez
desencadenado por los precios el aumento
de los precios de la energía por la
guerra en Ucrania que eso lleva
finalmente al aumento de todos los del
precio de todos los insumos básicos que
tienen encadenamiento de manera global
luego también está el problema de la
depreciación de las monedas que está
ligado a riesgos políticos riesgos
económicos y también sequías que en
algunos países de la región fue bastante
importante y luego también problemas de
déficit fiscal que hacen presión sobre
la inflación
intentando explicar un poco esas razones
de esa inflación Carlos Megan Lo que
pasa que esa inflación en el caso
europeo sí que viene muy marcado por el
componente energético por la Guerra de
Ucrania entendemos que en América no
tanto
de animaciones primas y de energía
entonces puede
utilizar su producción y también hay la
inflación viene más de los buenos
alimentarios y
sin embargo también hay una una difunda
de
los precios de buenos
básicos sobre el resto
de consumo se puede atacar con las
mismas recetas la inflación en un lado y
otro del Atlántico Carlos bueno no
existen instrumentos infinitos para
atacar los problemas inflacionarios en
este caso la raíz de problema es una
combinación de problemas de demanda no
es exactamente idéntico en el norte que
en el sur pero tiene parecidos como bien
dijo Vera
la historia inflacionaria de América
Latina quedó atrás salvo en dos casos en
Argentina y Venezuela casos de Gran
complejidad Argentina Por otra parte
corre el riesgo prontamente de entrar en
un ré inflacionario más parecido al de
los años 80 del cual resultó muy difícil
salir pero esto no aplica la mayoría de
los países el conjunto de países de
América Latina hay que mirar también los
niveles de deuda y de déficit fiscal que
tienen salvo el caso de Brasil Argentina
países como chile que ha tenido una
aceleración inflacionaria que no tiene
precedentes en los últimos 30 años de
chile sin embargo tiene mecanismo de
respuesta fuerte porque tiene grados de
libertad tiene un nivel de deuda bajo
igual que Paraguay y Perú eso le da más
grados de libertad el problema en el
norte tanto como en el sur es el el
tiempo de Prolongación del proceso
tanto en Estados Unidos como en Europa
más en Estados Unidos porque el mercado
de trabajo está más tenso que en Europa
si el proceso se alarga y esto tiene que
ver con la prolongación de la Guerra de
Ucrania que sostiene los sho oferta
pueden cambiar los mecanismos de
ajustes salariales en en las regiones Y
eso puede hacer que corramos el riesgo
de entrar a algo que hemos olvidado que
son fases de inflación más prolongadas
de manera que aquí es muy importante el
tipo de reacción de los bancos centrales
yo diría para concluir que en Estados
Unidos
la reserva Federal reaccionó de manera
muy lenta y hoy corre de atrás con el
problema aún con el aumento de tasas las
tasas siguen siendo reales negativas y
por eso en el riesgo de pérdida de
credibilidad el presidente de la reserva
Federal Power ahora está tornándose
sumamente agresivo para asentar
nuevamente la credibilidad en cambio en
el caso del Banco Central europeo la
subida de tipos de interés 0,5% en julio
0,75 enteros en septiembre
previsiblemente otra subida ahora en
octubre claro enfriar la economía es la
receta para la inflación pero no hay
recetas mágicas como decía Carlos Si no
atacamos de un lado es de otro no Sí tal
vez para para entender parte del
problema en el que estamos o en el que
está el mundo desarrollado
particularmente Europa es comprender
Cuál es la causa de la inflación actual
históricamente las inflaciones pueden
venir del lado de la oferta o de la
demanda si vienen del lado de la demanda
es porque los hogares están consumiendo
más eso es lo que dice la teoría si bien
el lado de la oferta es distinto Esta es
una inflación que viene del lado de la
oferta por varias ración razones Pero
principalmente es porque ya había una
crisis de la cadena de suministros y a
esa crisis se suma el problema de la
Guerra de Ucrania que ha hecho una que
aumenta el precio de la energía y de
otras materias primas Entonces es una es
una crisis de inflación que normalmente
se atacaría con una subida de tasas de
interés pero que en este caso ese no es
mecanismo para atacar una una inflación
producto de la oferta entonces la subida
de las clases de interés tienen el gran
riesgo de cómo dijo hace un momento
enfriar la economía reducir la inversión
Y eso probablemente va a reducir el
empleo en el 2023 y por eso es que
estamos hablando de una posible recesión
para entendernos
por supuesto la economía recordemos de
todas maneras que que hay algunos países
en América Latina que no están pensando
en aumentar la tasa de interés en el
corto plazo de hecho por ejemplo hay una
creencia muy kenesiana de que la
recuperación es vía la demanda Entonces
por ejemplo en este monto en Argentina
se vive con tasas reales de interés
negativas eso significa que es una
inflación muy fuerte Entonces no se
piensa en absoluto en aumentar la tasa
de interés hay también otras soluciones
que podría haber control de precios que
por supuesto también muchos gobiernos
dudan en ponerlo en marcha o algo que
también por supuesto es aumenta aún más
la inflación que es el aumento del
salario mínimo Por eso hay dos problemas
en América Latina importantes uno que
deja la clase media afuera y otro el
problema de la informalidad
que la demanda no es solamente para las
familias sino también para el estado y
el estado tiene que las autoridades
necesidad encontrar una equilibración y
políticas monetarias cambiar a fiscal
complementarias y trabaja juntos para
obtener una
una respuesta que permite por un lado
frente a la inflación y por otro lado
estimulado ayuda la
demanda especialmente a la a los pobres
porque
la inflación es como un impuesto sobre
los pobres luego hablaremos de
desigualdad antes el profesor vinograd
hablaba de la reserva Federal de cómo
había atacado el problema creo que decía
algo así como demasiado A lo mejor tarde
y poco en el caso del Banco Central
europeo se está diciendo que hay
críticos que dicen que demasiado machete
demasiado fuerte o bien o esas tasas de
las que estamos hablando 0,5,075 enteros
en septiembre una previsible subida en
octubre
Cómo calibramos el ritmo y la magnitud
en la que está actuando el BC bueno
obviamente la conducción de la política
monetaria tiene mucho de ciencia pero
mucho también de arte y
la realidad es que él ves el Banco
Central europeo ha evolucionado en la
práctica de su mandato era un mandato
muy
mimetizado de la historia del Banco
Central alemán que estaba basado en un
solo objetivo que era la estabilidad de
precios en la práctica durante la
administración de draghi evolucionó
hacia una práctica de facto que no está
en el mandato que es más parecida a la
de la reserva federal y la mayor parte
de los bancos centrales que es
considerar las cuestiones de empleo el
riesgo en esto tiene dos dimensiones
primero es que existen componentes de
oferta muy fuerte pero existen
componentes de demanda el aumento de la
liquidez internacional y la liquidez en
las regiones en los últimos 15 años en
particular para ajustar a la crisis de
2008 perduró en el tiempo no fue
reabsorbido completamente y eso ejerzo
una presión El Banco Central europeo al
cambiar un poco su actitud y volverse
más abierto tal vez corre el riesgo de
un exceso de confianza y en este sentido
creo que aquí hay que apelar al
principio de prudencia de las de las
inflaciones se sabe cómo se entra y
difícilmente se sabe cómo se sale
Entonces hay un riesgo enfrentar hay una
discusión en la literatura muy reciente
que es cuánto sería el costo en términos
de ajuste de empleo eso va a depender
pero en general las estimaciones para el
caso de Estados Unidos van entre 3 y 5%
debería subir la tasa de desempleo para
jugar el problema es que Europa salvo el
caso de Alemania y los Países Bajos
tiene tasa de desempleo más altas
entonces
este efecto puede operar sobre un piso
diferente pero quisiera señalar una cosa
no podemos ignorar que todo esto sucede
en el marco de un enorme crecimiento de
las deudas públicas de todos los países
del Norte estábamos aco usados a crisis
de deudas en América Latina Pero la
realidad es que hoy los países del Norte
Estados Unidos y Europa tienen una
enorme deuda pública y esto tiene dos
efectos cruzados la inflación
paradójicamente es una licuación reduce
la deuda pública respecto al producto
pero la suba de tasas ponen riesgos
sustentabilidad me van a dar un segundo
me tengo que ir a una breve pausa
enseguida seguimos hablando de la
inflación aquí en Primera Plana hasta
ahora
desinformación sustantivo femenino
información falsa o conjunto de acciones
que contribuyen a la desinformación del
público
el France 24 nuestro trabajo es
ofrecerles una información de calidad
nuestro rigor y nuestra independencia
nos permiten distinguir entre lo
verdadero y lo falso en los observadores
de France 24 verificamos las fotos y los
videos que circulan en internet si son
falsos se lo haremos saber y diremos
cómo identificarlos cada vez el mar de
la información en internet se hace más
turbulento por eso en Francia 24.com la
honestidad y el contexto están primero
France 24 información certificada
seguimos hablando de la inflación y sus
consecuencias esta semana en Primera
Plana lo hacemos con Álvaro Zúñiga
Cordero ver a kiodi Megan pullock y
Carlos vinograt en donde más se ha
sentido el aumento de precios es en la
canasta básica hay miedo de que se
agudice el hambre en la región ahora
mismo Vera Sí por supuesto que es una
posibilidad no conozco las estadísticas
en particular pero hay que pensar que el
aumento de estos del precio el petróleo
y de energías que son insumos básicos
que tienen encadenamientos con todos los
precios hay algunos países a ver
digamoslo de manera clara que se están
beneficiando finalmente el aumento de
precios como consecuencia la Guerra de
Ucrania los que exportan trigo los que
exportan soja o petróleo Pero cuál es el
problema que el efecto neto no es
particularmente positivo luego tienen
que importar a su vez productos
derivados del petróleo que ser aumentado
y pensemos que no sectores más pobres el
ingreso está totalmente dedicado al
consumo y el consumo justamente que va a
vivienda que va alimentas alimentos ese
ahí donde aumentó
digamos el mayor aumento es ahí en los
alimentos esas desigualdades pueden
crecer en la región ahora en esta
situación
haya una riesgo de ocultación de la de
la alhambra porque con la alimentación
de la incidencia de la pobreza en el
2021 con la con la pandemia había
40 pacientes de la población que es en
seguridad alimentaria y también es
importante notar que son las mujeres las
que más sufren de la hambre en América
las mujeres
estamos hablando de la inflación
Parecen dos males que hay que calibrar
estos días y de la recesión no es la
recesión peor que la inflación o lo que
hace o lo que hace mal a esta inflación
es su alto nivel sostenido en el tiempo
cómo calibramos estos dos males el de la
inflación y el de la recesión
la recesión es A mi criterio mucho peor
es mucho peor porque implica pérdida de
empleo
y si eso ocurre el El golpe sobre todo
para los hogares de más bajo ingreso va
a ser mucho peor en el tiempo Ahí es
donde hay que pensar calibrar las
políticas
monetarias con las políticas Fiscales y
la recomendación en este caso es hay que
hay que calibrar la política monetaria
es inevitable hay una inflación y los
bancos centrales tienen muchos años de
estar respondiendo a esto con una subida
de tasas de interés pero la respuesta no
se puede quedar ahí y hay que ajustar la
política fiscal de tal manera que no se
puede captar menos y lo que hay que
hacer es hacer políticas de corta
duración y focalizadas En aquellos
hogares o sectores de la población que
son los que más van a sufrir
entre dos males pero recordemos que en
la región hay una historia inflacionaria
que si bien salvo estos dos casos
existe esta cosa de ajuste de
expectativas la gente reacciona muy
rápido O sea que hay que también tener
en cuenta eso que hay mucha memoria que
está todavía presente como ver el
análisis de estos dos males Carlos bueno
como como dice la literatura a veces
la peste y el cólera
no debemos ignorar que que la inflación
es el impuesto más regresivo que
conocemos por lo tanto un proceso
perdurable de inflación tiene dos
efectos uno afecta a los sectores más
desfavorecidos de manera más fuerte que
otros que tienen más acceso a los
instrumentos financieros se pueden
proteger de otra manera y por otra parte
cuando y vuelvo al punto inicial a veces
un ex Primer Ministro de Francia una vez
me dijo Es lamentable Pero la realidad
es que a los políticos no no se evalúan
por lo que evitamos sino por lo que se
ve y a veces el riesgo político de
procrastinar Es decir de convivir con
ciertos males puede tornarse que el
costo interior es alto Por ejemplo si la
inflación se instala luego las pérdidas
de empleo se pueden llegar a ser mucho
más fuertes que un corte súbito a un
proceso inflacionario evidentemente como
con toda medicina el exceso puede ser
tóxico entonces ahí está más el arte que
la ciencia de la política
entonces lo que estamos viendo Es que lo
complicado es el bisturí Y a lo que se
le ha criticado las críticas que se ha
hecho el Banco Central europeo es ir a
machete las políticas monetaria es muy
Macro no ve cuestiones de distribución
Por supuesto que le hace muy bien
algunos sectores y no le hacen le hace
bastante mal a otros Entonces por
supuesto hace falta acciones
complementarias sí es importante que la
política fiscal viene a corregir y a y
ayudar a las personas que necesitan
ayuda y
por eso el FM el que manda a operación
masivas en particular para
para afrontar los precios altos de
energía y no recuerdas
[Música]
subvenciones general para proteger la
estabilidad fiscal también de los países
es decir una política fiscal que también
en estas situaciones de contexto se debe
hacer con bisturí y no los organismos
recomiendan no prometer bajadas
generalizadas de impuesto en esas
circunstancias totalmente es que no se
puede captar menos en un momento en el
que hay dos temas fundamentales uno hay
que gastar más de manera inusual porque
hay que proteger y acompañar aquellos
que van a ser más afectados por la
inflación o eventualmente por la pérdida
de empleo y tampoco se puede captar
menos en un escenario en el que las
tasas de interés suben y el costo de la
deuda sube entonces en otras palabras
para los Estados especialmente para
aquellos que captan en una moneda
distinta a las suyas no es recomendable
aumentar su deuda cuando están creciendo
los costos de esa deuda muy sintomático
es el caso de la nueva Premier británica
listras que llegó ganó las primarias
prometiendo bajada generalizada de
impuestos y ahora se da cuenta que
gastar más con menos O sea soplar y
absorber es imposible en economía Carlos
Sí el efectivamente soplar Y absorber la
metáfora Es buena el caso del Reino
Unido es un es un caso muy particular
que merecería una reunión porque comenzó
con el referéndum de Cameron y el fin de
su historia política
y luego el brexit y luego hoy el Reino
Unido está en una situación
extremadamente compleja desde el punto
de vista económico con una caída sin
precedentes de la libra sin entrar en
una en una en una discusión
la capacidad de los gobiernos de hacer
políticas expansionistas depende la
situación inicial de stocks países con
más deuda van a tener más limitaciones
para hacer estas políticas de las cuales
bien están hablando Álvaro o Megan Por
ejemplo si estábamos el caso de América
Latina paradójicamente los países que
han sido más prudentes en el pasado
tiene más poder de fuego el caso de
chile Perú a pesar de su inestabilidad
política tiene niveles de deuda bajos y
puede permitirse respuestas Fiscales más
fuertes se ha visto en la pandemia el
país más expansionista de la pandemia
fue chile en América Latina Entonces no
se puede en abstracto dar proposiciones
generales en el caso de Europa la
situación es muy compleja porque el país
más afectado que es Alemania porque el
shock de oferta y su dependencia
energética del este es la más fuerte es
el país que por otro lado tiene las
tasas de desempleo más bajas de manera
que parte de una situación más favo en
el que otros países
endeudarse de sacar un plan de 200.000
lo que vale que claro Los Socios de
alrededor de Europa lo ven con recelo
lógicamente cuando la teoría alemana
antes era otra distinto
lo podríamos marcar como una buena señal
el plan alemán Alemania tiene una deuda
que es 40 o 50 por ciento más baja que
países como Francia la mitad que la
deuda relación al producto que tiene
Italia o Bélgica entonces nuevamente
nuevamente con la prudencia del pasado
le permite tener más poder de fuego hoy
sin embargo Aquí hay un elemento desde
el punto de vista europeo muy
interesante que es la situación de
Francia con una autonomía energética más
fuerte que tal vez si las cosas salen
bien permita hacer un gesto que sea de
Retorno a de solidaridad Europea y
colaborar con la situación de Alemania y
esto sea un muy buen Push para la Unión
Europea
el caso francés Francia al fin y al cabo
ha conseguido controlar la inflación
mucho mejor que el resto de socios
europeos se debe sobre todo entendemos
al escudo energético no
al llamado escudo energético a los topes
que ha fijado hasta el año que viene el
gobierno francés entendemos que esa es
la gran causa por la cual los datos de
inflación de Francia Son menores que los
del resto de socios europeos
para entender la inflación en general y
la francesa vale la pena descomponer Qué
elemento de la economía están
contribuyendo a su inflación y en
Francia es sorprendente que el año
pasado por ejemplo en el 2020 la energía
tenía una contribución negativa la
inflación más bien los precios de la
energía están reduciendo la inflación
total y eso lo que está aumentando a
partir del 2020 pero en una situación
que está mucho mejor que los otros
países europeos que no pueden o no
tienen los elementos para producir su
propia energía muy importante hablamos
de una crisis que sigue a otra porque
estamos hablando de Ucrania que sigue a
la de la covid pero claro Hay una que va
a continuar porque la guerra acabará
pero la crisis climática Va a continuar
de condenar al escenario inflacionista
global la crisis la crisis climática que
no se va a resolver mañana
y no sabemos si se va a hablar
creo que es muy pertinente mira lo que
ocurre en el norte en Estados Unidos y
en Europa porque los países de la región
tienen la característica de tener una
moneda
es una generalidad para todos los países
bastante frágil son sistemas
bimonetarios pero recordemos también que
el contexto actual para los países este
frágil gobernanza con muchos conflictos
sociales aún con países con gobiernos de
izquierda y que en ese sentido va a ser
difícil manejar el espacio fiscal
reducido Megan alguna punta más
claro a los países deben poner en caso
medidas a
largo plazo y necesita inmigración
necesita financiación
y lo que es lo que es difícil en conte
de tasas de interés altos Entonces es
como
una falta de tiempo para poner estas
estas medidas que serán muy importantes
por el futuro pero si el problema es
obtener las financiación necesarias para
para eso pues muchísimas gracias Es un
placer compartir este tiempo con ustedes
Carlos Megan Vera y Álvaro un placer
haber compartido este tiempo con ustedes
muy complicadas a veces explicar la
economía pero yo creo que no somos
aproximado un escenario global que es lo
que estamos viendo y nos han dado
muchísimas claves te lo agradezco
muchísimo a los cuatro y a todos ustedes
les esperamos aquí en Primera Plana la
próxima semana Muchas gracias
[Música]